so today i'm talking about one of my
favorite topics galaxy clusters because
it's what i research as well and also
one of my favorite images
so galaxy clusters are essentially what
their names tells you clusters of
galaxies hundreds if not thousands of
galaxies that orbit around one another
and they're held together by their
gravity so these are like gravitational
giants of our universe they're 10 to the
14 solar masses typically that's a lot
heavier than our sun they're the largest
gravitationally bound objects that we
know of in our universe also because of
their huge gravitational potential wells
this heats up gas to
hundreds of millions of kelvin in
temperature and that radiates very
brightly in x-rays so we can see with
our x-ray telescopes this bright hot gas
this is one of my favorite pictures it's
the bullet cluster it's not a single
image it's not taken by a single
telescope but it's a composite of many
images you can see stars and galaxies
taken by the hubble space telescope so
this is optical and infrared light so
you can see very clearly very high
resolution stars and galaxies but what
we also have here is these two distinct
blobs so even though it's called a
bullet cluster this isn't really a
single galaxy cluster it's actually two
clusters that have collided together and
you can see this giant
region of stars and galaxies here and
then this smaller sub galaxy cluster
here what we're seeing in the pink or
reddish color is imagery taken by nasa's
chandra telescope and this is a space
telescope that observes in the x-ray and
like i just said galaxy clusters because
of their huge gravitational potential
wells they heat up this gas to millions
of degrees kelvin that shine brightly in
x-rays so you can see this hot gas and
because of this collision they've
already collided they're moving away
from each other you can see the gas has
shocked and you can see even like a
bowfront on this part of the gas after
it's kind of plowed through each other
what we're also seeing here is this blue
or even purpley light color this is a
mass map taken by eso's wfi instrument
the mass map tells us where most of the
mass is in our system it's determined
from
the weak gravitational lensing data so
recall that gravitational lensing is
when you have like a huge massive object
with gravity as light from distant
galaxies passes through the vicinity of
this gravitational potential it distorts
this light and so you see it in like the
distortions of the galaxies by measuring
the ellipticities and the distortions of
these faraway galaxies you can figure
out where most of the mass is as the
light has traveled through it towards us
this paints a really interesting picture
because what we're seeing here is that
most of the mass it doesn't follow the
gas it does follow the stars and
galaxies there's not much like in
between when the galaxy clusters collide
they pass through each other because the
galaxies are just so far apart it's
mostly empty space they pass straight
through but the mass also follows that
it's passed right through it hasn't
shocked
like the gas and so this image
is our best evidence that we have it's
our only direct evidence essentially
we have of dark matter dark matter is
dark in that it doesn't emit any light
but it doesn't absorb any light either
it's the missing piece of our universe
because it explains for example galaxy
rotation curves and other observables
that we have it makes what we see in the
universe makes sense we think that
galaxy clusters contain ninety percent
dark matter about nine percent hot gas
and only one percent of like stars and
galaxies and so if dark matter makes up
most of our galaxy cluster then we would
expect most of this mass to be
observations of dark matter and so dark
matter is weakly interacting it doesn't
really interact with anything and even
though we say weakly interacting that
doesn't mean that it interacts with the
weak force it only interacts through
gravity so it doesn't shock it passes
right through and causes these distinct
kind of separations the bullet cluster
also provides the best evidence against
a
alternative theory of gravity known as
mind modified newtonian dynamics so some
people don't believe that dark matter
exists because we've never been able to
detect it so some people have come up
with alternative theories and mond is
one of the most common ones this is
where you modify newton's law such that
at high accelerations you expect gravity
to be less than at low acceleration so
it's just like a factor that you add on
into newton's laws and it it makes these
like galaxy rotation curves work but mon
doesn't work for the bullet cluster
because the separation between the dark
matter or the mass and the hot gas is
just too large to be explained by a
small factor and actually the original
proposer of monde even said that the
bullet cluster proves that dark matter
exists and since the bullet cluster we
know of many galaxy clusters just like
this one here you can see some of the
examples of colliding galaxy clusters
and their measurements and these are
actually really important because by
measuring the offsets between the mass
and the hot gas we can get constraints
on the cross-section of dark matter so
how large they are if dark matter is
larger
then you would expect them to be less
drag
so moving less apart from the the hot
gas but if they're smaller you would
expect it to move past even even more
but this isn't the end because there are
examples that disagree and so for
example this is known as the train wreck
cluster another galaxy cluster but if
you look at the
x-rays the weak lensing
and the optical separately see the
lensing has this like
sausage-like shape the x-ray gas is all
squished together what we know about
dark matter what we think we know about
dark matter it cannot explain this
galaxy cluster so
it's not the end of it yet there's still
loads to learn from these types of
systems
because if you think about it it's as if
you had all the stars running long
distance race where they all stay in
lane and if you really ran a long
distance race that way the people in the
outside lanes would be hugely
disadvantaged because they've got a
whole lot further to go this is guilford
again here in here in britain this is
the sort of phenomena that most people
would have seen these afterglows were
very widely reported and very beautiful